toi tu lui
le ciel était immaculé les vins sont
tombés sp sexe à gagner son pari et
qu'elle paris son lanceur falcon et v la
fusée la plus puissante du monde a
réalisé des collages parfait à cap
canaveral en floride
comparé à ses compétiteurs forte comme
et v est un monstre l'appui grosse fusé
depuis les énormes cette somme 5 de la
nasa qui ont transporté les astronautes
vers la lune au de 23 étages l'a27
moteur une poussée équivalente au
décollage de 18 boeing 747
comme prévu 2 minutes 30 après son
départ de lens or se sont détachés de
falcon avait pour amorcer le retour sur
terre
un retour qui frôlait lui aussi la
perfection d'abord les rétrofusées
qu'une descente en douceur et finalement
une intérêts sage en simultané sur le
sucre de space text la fusée principal a
repris le même chemin un peu plus tard
mais son retour devrait faire comme
celui ci sur une base dans l'atlantique
dans l'espace
il ne reste que la magnifique tesla
rouge vif du propriétaire de space x
elon musk embarqué comme unique
cargaison avec un peu de chance elle
orbite sera dans quelques mois autour de
la planète mars
à long terme l'objectif avoué de
l'extravagant milliardaire sud africain
pour plusieurs raisons la réussite de
spacex représente une étape que l'on
peut qualifier d'historique dans
l'aventuré spatiale la course à l'espace
est ralentie depuis longtemps par les
coûts d'opération faramineux des
lanceurs aujourd'hui spacek affirme que
falcon et v peut mettre en orbite trois
fois plus de charge utile que ses
concurrents pour un prix deux à trois
fois plus bas si c'est exact il pourrait
y avoir pas mal plus d'action en
périphérie de la terre
quelques années ici normand grondin
reste du canada montréal
[Applaudissements]